alright guys sorry to have to break this
to you
there's a study out here that shows that
consuming eggs now will clog your
arteries and actually kill you
prematurely so I'm gonna have to delete
all my videos now and eggs and
cholesterol and completely recommend a
different thing because according to
this study associations of dietary
cholesterol or egg consumption with
incident cardiovascular disease in
mortality I'm gonna have to completely
change my recommendations according to
this study and here's the conclusion
among US adults higher consumption of
dietary cholesterol or eggs with
significantly associated with higher
risk of incident of cardiovascular
disease and all cause mortality
basically eggs are going to kill you now
I hope you guys realize that I have a
very dry sense of humor and this is
sarcasm to the extreme because this
study is BS on steroids so the people
that are using this study to prove the
point the eggs are bad either never read
it
they don't understand it it's over their
head or they hope no one reads it let's
go through the points the first thing
you want to do when you look at a study
is find out who funded this study
okay well multiple pharmaceutical
companies and other related businesses
who profit from the results check this
out conflict of interest disclosures dr.
Wilkins reported receiving consultation
fees from NGM biopharmaceuticals and
then dr. mints reported receiving
research support from all sorts of
companies including AstraZeneca Bayer
GlaxoSmithKline Medtronic Merck no Varys
Abbott and the list goes on and on and
on so right there I could pretty much
stop that's a huge conflict of interest
how are these researchers are going to
be unbiased they're getting paid by
companies that possibly have another
interest alright next point this was an
observational study okay the data was
taken from six other studies over
seventeen point six
with 29,000 615 people between the ages
of 34 and 79 both men and female now an
observational study is a study which
uses a food frequency questionnaire this
is not a clinical study where they're
using randomized controls no they're
using a question here over a period of
17.6 years that is so subjective how is
someone going to remember what they ate
even last week and they don't tell you
how frequently these questionnaires are
passed out it could be a year it could
be every five years who knows but the
point is that this is not objective it's
not reliable a study is only as good as
the data is true incredible so
self-reported questionnaires are at the
lowest bottom barrel of scientific
studies all right next thing what did
they evaluate how many variables did
they look at one they based this very
strong conclusion on looking at one
thing eggs that's it and eggs associated
you know cardiovascular disease and
death did they look at whether the
person ate Donuts their sugar level
carbohydrate content the stress level no
how about smoking no how much exercise
they did absolutely not soda consumption
if they had diabetes or not no none of
this was looked at that was all omitted
they looked at one thing eggs so realize
- when they use the word association
that has nothing to do with causation
cause and effect at all
so another term for this is miss
classification bias that's really what
they're doing alright let's look at a
couple other things here number one the
data is just not reliable the
questionnaires very subjective had the
lowest credibility they were only
looking at one variable no blood test
they didn't look at your LDL HDL the
type of LDL they didn't look at other
reasons why these people had heart
failure and died like what about cancer
HIV liver I mean a person eventually is
going to die and the hearts gonna give
up it's not always a clogged artery that
causes the heart attack there are other
reasons they didn't look at that and
also they didn't mention all the studies
that show opposing findings okay so you
can see there are quite a few studies
that show no relationship between the
intake of eggs and serum cholesterol
here's another one total dietary
cholesterol levels have no significant
effects on plasma LDL here's another one
found no association with eggs and
cardiovascular disease dietary
consumption of eggs was not associated
with cardiovascular disease here's
another one no association with
cardiovascular disease and here's
another one 2009 by Jones no association
between egg consumption and
cardiovascular disease alright guys in
summary anytime someone uses science to
prove something make sure you personally
look at the study see if the data is
truthful or not because this study is
just complete and utter BS so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications